in Washington the negotiators who worked
out a deal to raise a debt limit plan to
spend the rest of a hectic holiday
weekend promoting it the drama is far
from over lawmakers on both sides are
criticizing concessions made by
President Biden and house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy Scott McFarland is on Capitol
Hill and looks at what's in the deal and
the work that still has to be done Scott
good morning hey Vlad good morning to
you at long last an agreed-upon bill was
released last night so for speaker Kevin
McCarthy and President Biden the task
shifts now to selling this deal to
members of their both both of their
parties all that being said when
Congress returns after this holiday
weekend political fireworks are certain
after a weekend of high stakes
negotiations President Biden and the
Republican house speakers say they're
confident they've brokered a two-year
deal to lift the debt ceiling by four
trillion dollars extending it until
after the 2024 election it takes a
threat of catastrophic to fall off the
table protects our hard-earned and
historic economic recovery
and the agreement also represents the
compromise and that it will satisfy
enough members of Congress to assure it
passes before the June 5th deadline the
treasury is set to avoid default it
doesn't get everything everybody wanted
but that's in divided government that's
where we end up the deal prevents cuts
to Social Security and Medicare as well
as the military and Veterans programs it
also claws back funding from the IRS 10
billion dollars in both fiscal years
2024 and 2025 and it takes back the
unspent money from covid relief funds it
also loosens some environmental rules it
temporarily adds work requirements for
some social safety net programs
including food stamps terrible policy
absolutely terrible policy the chair of
the democratic Progressive caucus voiced
concerns about those new requirements I
think it is uh really unfortunate that
the president opened the door to this
while a group of Republicans in the
conservative Freedom caucus say the deal
doesn't cut enough spending or reduce
the deficit Congressman Ralph Norman
tweeted the deal was Insanity while his
colleague chip Roy colorfully called it
a turd sandwich opposition on both sides
gives the deal a narrow path to passage
it'll require votes from both sides of
the aisle but house leaders are voicing
confidence they'll get it done I do
expect that there will be Democratic
support this is a good strong bill that
a majority of Republicans will vote for
the White House had a zoom meeting with
Democrats Sunday night to urge their
support for this agreement speaker Kevin
McCarthy wrote an op-ed for the Wall
Street Journal in the U.S Senate there
is also a narrow path to passage and
they could vote by Friday or by the
weekend Tony
it's got to believe the congressman
there called it a quote turd sandwich
and Vlad here who used to work in
banking said look when you got to eat
anything sounds good thank you very much